one of the first prosecution witnesses
in derrick chauvin's trial was an
eyewitness named donald williams it was
a bystander video captured him
repeatedly
asking officers to check george floyd's
pulse
williams told the court that he believed
he had witnessed a murder
donald williams joins us now with his
attorney antonio romanucci welcome
gentlemen it's good to see you both
donald really excited to talk to you
this morning because so many people were
moved by your testimony
what did you think when you heard the
verdict yesterday did you think it was
even possible
yeah um you know i had a little
worriedness on it
um but you know i actually sat there and
prayed with uh me and my kids and
right before the verdict and we watched
it and
prayer came through and yes
we heard your 9-1-1 call during the
court
you were clearly moved to tears by that
what was it like for you to see derrick
chauvin in person
in the courtroom
it was a tough emotional situation to
actually see him for the first time
from the incident and just actually
having a
eye connection and you know just being
able to be in the same presence
it was it was tough and a little
challenging but
we was able to get through
what did you think donald when the
defense tried to portray you it seemed
like they were trying to portray you as
mr angry black man on the scene
i thought that you i know it's funny now
isn't it it wasn't so funny i thought at
the time
but what did you think of that
characterization of you because you
clearly were not having it
yeah i definitely uh you know like i'm
smiling now
i i realized it was coming and i just
put a smile on my face and
you know i i just think it's you know
terrible that you know
as a black man that you know we get
painted as an angry
person or angry black man you know and
and it sucks that you know we i had to
go up there and
endure that and you know now the world
sees that as well that you know
they paint us out as an angry person
even when you're telling the truth like
all i'm doing is telling the truth and
what i've seen in my side of the story
you know
and you know he tried to pay me out as
being angry for speaking up
for floyd's life and you know trying to
stop a murder that i witnessed
yeah under the circumstances donald
considering what you were watching
how were you able to say how were you
able to stay so composed
it was clear that you were pleading for
george floyd's life
with derrick chauvin pleading several
times
because you knew what you were
witnessing
yes correct so i you know i always go
back to wrestling and
and makes martial arts and just my
family you know and
just you know being a black man growing
up in america you know you got to be
able to compose yourself under pressure
you got to be able to you know not being
able to you know get seen angry or you
know make the wrong movements or things
like that
so in that situation i just really was
in my head visualizing everything that
was happening
and making sure that you know i use my
martial arts and my visualization and
things not to
you know react the wrong way or make the
wrong moves or do too much that it
causes harm from myself
and not only the people around me as
well
yes attorney ramanuchi i'd like to know
what you're thinking ben crump called
this a turning point for this country
do you think that it will lead to real
change sir
i do uh gail i think this is the first
time at least in
in my lifetime in my career that i can
almost say that i have
a very very eternal hope for change
um may 25th and april 20th those are the
two bookend dates i think where
we realize that now justice in america
can come forward
i think it will happen we've seen it
happen in states across the country in
their police reform
and certainly now we know that in
washington d.c we have a monumental bill
that's waiting for senate approval and
then on to the president's desk
i i know that change is coming i've seen
it and
and it will continue well we all hope
you're right
donald i'd like to know how you're doing
mentally considering what you watched so
many witnesses said that they
that they felt guilty that they're still
struggling with it how are you doing and
you have
we have less than 30 seconds donald
yeah uh you know it's tough it's tough
nights you know and um
i'm just trying to stay mentally tough
with it you know and not let it you know
consume me and eat me up so much but uh
it is a tough situation and watch a
tragedy like that
and yeah i'm dealing with it you know
and it's going to be some time but
i'm getting there thank you to my team
around me though well please
please know we are so glad you were
there that day the prosecutor called you
a bouquet of humanity that is certainly
you